welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and black widow had an alternate
ending revealed in a deleted scene that
finally clears up some of the questions
we had regarding the timeline of events
as the black widow movie wrapped up no
i'm not talking about what was in
scarlet's contract regarding streaming
prophets buzz off hollywood lawyers not
only a deleted alternate ending we're
also now seeing an alternate take of the
post-credits scene between val and elena
that would have given a different final
line of the movie and another deleted
scene between secretary ross and
natasha's supplier rick mason that helps
explain the timeline of the third act
while also presenting some new
possibilities about taskmaster i'm gonna
break it all down for you okay the
alternate ending scene would have taken
place before natasha met back up with
rick mason to get the quinjet natasha
returns to her old ohio neighborhood the
one that she and her family fled in
1995. kids are out playing some girls do
a synchronized dance and then a bunch of
cooler kids appear to be larping as
avengers one girl has a set of falcon
wings another kid chose to be hawkeye i
guess all the good ones were taken now
another kid wears green and padding
underneath to look like hulk not to
assume too much here but could this be a
young amadeus cho one kid wears these
wrist straps at point like iron man
repulsors another worthier child carries
mjolnir as thor another kid carries a
cap shield natasha gazes upon her old
house her hair changed to the short
blonde haircut that she wears an
infinity war also elena's vest the cap
kid and another girl wearing widow's
bites made out of crayons oh she shares
this adorable moment with natasha
i gotta say i love this despite the risk
natasha is definitely taking as a
fugitive ross's forces would probably
have her old house being watched this
girl playing black widow and the boy
playing cat pairing off in front of
natasha might have even been what
inspired natasha to team up with cap to
help him free sam and wanda from the
raft prison while the theatrical ending
of the film makes those next steps more
explicit i think for some that also
elicited some mental readjustment of the
other events at the end of civil war
that in order for natasha to sync up
with cap in that final shot in the raft
all of the events of black widow must
have taken place during the epilogue of
civil war an epilogue that now must have
lasted weeks like the red room fell from
the freaking sky all while tony stank
was kicking it with roadie i mean we got
it it just took us a second to process
while we were also trying to appreciate
the bookending significance of the
fireflies really the bigger timeline
mystery from the end of black widow was
how did natasha slip secretary ross as
he was closing in on her the movie just
kind of cuts to black and then two weeks
later she's with mason and that new
haircut and no explanation as to how she
was able to elude ross in an open field
well another recently revealed deleted
scene shed some light on ross and
mason's movements in the latter half of
this film in this scene ross and his
forces find this restaurant and have
mason in captivity where did you serve
mr secretary
i am serving this very instant right
here in front of you
as i have my whole life what i don't do
is sell myself to the highest bidder
propping myself up like some debonair
black market
smuggler ross is then given a phone that
was left behind by natasha in a box of
french fries with a note reading come
after me and her hourglass logo and then
this would have led into melina waking
up in her natasha disguise in the red
room holding cell so this would have
shown where mason ended up after
worrying to natasha that ross had been
hot on his heels your mate secretary
ross has been sniffing around my affairs
to the point to which i've got contacts
declining my calls it also would have
explained how ross got the word to track
down natasha at the red room's precise
location which in the theatrical version
was a bit of logic rushed in via audio
dubbed in later via adr so once we're
inside i'll activate my tracker and
russell come running but before i
continue this video is brought to you by
our friends at manscaped the best in
men's below the waste grooming manscaped
offers precision engineered tools for
your family jewels they just launched
their fourth generation trimmer the
lawnmower 4.0 and it is a doozy it's got
an led light it's got wireless charging
and an adjustable guard with four length
settings now as with the previous lawn
mowers the 4.0 has a ceramic blade with
skin safe technology you know to avoid
the bag snags the pouch ouch the
puncture of your private juncture
they've also got products like the weed
whacker nose hair trimmer their crop
preserver their crop reviver so if
you're still using a face razor to trim
your non-face hair you might as well be
scrubbing your armpits with your
toothbrush join over 2 million men
worldwide who trust manscaped make
yourself a little less beast and a
little more silver surfer get 20 off and
free shipping with the code loki at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscape.com use the code
loki unlock your confidence and always
use the right tools for the job with
manscape now we never saw this
restaurant in the film though the trucks
that surround it are hungarian for varga
and company land and sea shipping so
this would be somewhere outside budapest
and knowing that mason was with ross's
forces at this point could tell us how
natasha might have been able to wriggle
out of ross's clutches assuming that
ross probably detained her from this
crash field and now in this deleted
scene mason seems to be sizing up ross's
operation it did look a bit off the
books at least stretching its
jurisdiction whereas mason is on his
home field in budapest he's got a
network of resources that he's been
using to help natasha this whole time he
totally could have pre-arranged some
black market mercenaries to start a
firefight with ross's limited size group
here at which point natasha after she's
already been detained alongside mason
the two of them could have escaped
during that chaotic crossfire which
could be why mason later tells natasha
when they reunite i've been in six
different time zones in three days
because of you yeah six different time
zones budapest is six time zones ahead
of ohio which seems to be where mason
and natasha now are based on those same
fireflies being in the trees is the
opening shot in ohio and now we've
blurred natasha driving the same
motorcycle that we saw her on in the
deleted alternate indian scene that was
in ohio now as to why this scene with
ross and mason was cut it could just be
a simple matter of pacing that's usually
the reason why these things are cut out
of the movie but it's still interesting
to see ross's resentment toward mason
for selling his skills to the highest
bidder instead of serving his country
and how the way ross says it it seems
like it's so personal for him now there
have been some theories out there that
rick mason could have been the original
identity of taskmaster but then they
re-shot it to be antonia drakov when
that leaked i'm not sure about that
because antonia drakov seemed pretty
baked into the narrative throughout the
film and changing the movie to that
would have required extensive reshoots
and all the reports say the movie went
unchanged for the past year now i've
always believed that the taskmaster
identity doesn't have to end with
antonia and since it's tech another
character could totally take that on
based on this new tension from ross here
i would love to see rick mason pressured
into serving his country once more under
the mask of taskmaster as part of ross
and val's thunderbolts initiative and
speaking of val in that initiative this
movie's post-credit scene in which she
assigns the elena velova who's also part
of that group with john walker the
movie's outtakes reveal an alternate bit
of dialogue improvised by julia louie
dreyfus as much of that interaction
probably was can i have my pen keeping
it
okay well
merry christmas
so which ending of black widow do you
prefer you can support new rock stars by
checking out all of our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavos follow
and subscribe to new rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you